well there it is why'd you make me do
this hi there I'm aria
and today I received some wine in the
mail so I'm not actually excited
specifically about the wine because I
really don't know anything about wine
however this wine has a very peculiar
history which I'm intrigued by it's give
a little sip first huh that's wine what
I find particularly interesting about
this wine is that it is in fact produced
by the fellowship of friends a religious
group which according to the LA Times
and the San Francisco Chronicle has been
called a cult by ex-members the
fellowship of friends most successful
venture however is the Renaissance
vineyard and winery which produced some
of the best wines to come out of
California until it shut down in 2015 in
the 1990s
Gideon vine stock was a wine maker and
produced some of the most legendary and
extraordinarily long-lived wines the
wines had been served to u.s. presidents
and respected by wine experts I find
this quite interesting that's something
that could be quite revered can also
have a potentially sordid past so while
I may not know too much about wine
myself I do have some friends around the
office that I'd like to share some of
this wine with as well as perhaps some
historical tidbits about this religious
group no should I say that I am damn
dude I love wine I drink a lot of red
wine Bordeaux's I like cabs as well
there's some sort of a catch here you're
gonna read me why in fact obviously wish
and blaze 2012 reserved
Renaissance Cabernet Sauvignon has
everyone felt like this is a prank yeah
I know why because it's you how's it
smell like wine it's a little taste test
you know let's go crazy I feel like I'm
gonna be so mad after I taste it yeah we
have to work together again I was a
little nervous and now I am definitely
more excited because I love life you
like wine Joyce I do
[Music]
a little watery smells good I know I'm
nervous I feel like this is a mistake
it shouldn't agree to videos of Aria
makes good yeah it tastes just like
church wine plan it's gonna be something
where it's like whoever made this is
like that or something it doesn't have a
distinct flavor it has no real taste
it's just wine and not even good one I
just gotta take mostly tastes great so
I'm not tasting like any wood or any you
trying to taste one when you drink wine
well actually use the facts about it
this is now touched in my mouth
oh is this one of those videos oh I knew
it
which according to the San Francisco
Chronicle and the LA Times
cult I knew it okay tell me about the
friends I'm trying to divorce it from it
mattering that I drank this one because
I didn't pay for the one okay I'm
surprised it's good you know what this
was on me cuz I knew it the fellowship
of friends was founded by Robert Earl
Burton in 1970 in the San Francisco Bay
Area according to the organization's
official website from its inception the
vision of the fellowship was and
remained to establish a practical
spiritual organization and to make it
available to anyone interested in
pursuing the spiritual work of awakening
fellowship of friends it sounds friendly
sounds like weird fellowship of friends
great club name they usually find a
source of income for at least and we can
create wines for president spiritual
work of Awakening is something that I
would put as a description of an alleged
cult we loved awakening we love opening
the third our i we love breaking the
matrix we love the simulation yeah I
don't like the vagueness of it there's a
lot of vague language in that hmm just
like come for the awakening it doesn't
specify which religion it doesn't
specify what kind of deity they might
believe in the vagueness means they're
hiding something I'm just waiting for
you to tell me that they like touched
people or something according to the SF
Chronicle Burton was believed to have
been visited by angelic incarnations of
Walt
and Leonardo da Vinci he has also
predicted or prophesized a number of
cultural and natural disasters including
an economic collapse in 1980 for the
destruction of California in 1998 and
Armageddon in 2006 and some kind of
other disaster in 2018 he prophesized
that these things were gonna happen he's
running out on any thought I was making
good one and he was wrong eleventh I
wonder what they put in the wine oh yeah
what if I'm gonna start seeing ghosts
after drinking this uh at least we'll
get away from thinking that this is a
tale is all this time a guy believes
grandiose thoughts about himself rope
some people in cells a single product to
fund him it's hard because he and I grew
up in the church there would be a lot of
passage to prophesize the future and
like they would be wrong I don't think
they'd fool me unless it was like a
winery
we're awakening Leonardo da Vinci was
like a Oh Joyce what's up I'm like yo
dude I love a 1996 LA Times article
reports that membership once exceeded
2500 but today the fellowship has only
around 500 members the full amount of
people they still have members that's a
big drop is Gideon okay is he still
doing it he did no oh my god the same
article claims that the organization
expects members to pay 10 percent of
their income for membership fees I can't
afford that which is probably not a lot
of money anyway but 10 percent of your
income thanks a lot I mean there's a
pay-to-play on basically everything like
you can't even go to the gym without
pain like a membership fee so it's like
if you're gonna be with the fellowship
or friends they got wine to make I mean
I'm probably giving 10% in rent right so
a group that I won't name try to get me
to pay to being like their classes or
whatever and I was just like if it's not
free it's not for me
no I gotta think about all the things
that I use my money for they kind of get
all that for free right
I hope make the wine I'll put on my
sandals and I'll stop in the grapes and
junk but to give 10% of my income
I mean thing I got hoes the fee in 1996
the LA Times also reported that some
behavior of burton's was exceedingly
controlling such as telling members to
stop wearing eyeglasses and compelling
them to wear contacts instead he also
told married couples to wait for five
years before having children and for a
while women were forced to wear skirts
only according to this same article
burden claim to be celibate saving his
sexual energy for the good of his
well there it is why did you make me do
this not good at all I put down the wine
glass at this point in the video what do
you do I feel awful about drinking this
wine how do you take a shower on the
inside of your body and I don't want to
be holding this wine wearing glasses
thing is weird really stands out he
wants to see those eyes
no daddy keeps those eyes on the case
say five years after getting married I
want to make sure you enjoy the
relationship you don't want to bring
kids into the mix I just said it wasn't
that good before saving his sexual
energy for the good of the flock but I
can't imagine it's anything good my
final times I hate this and I hate you
and I hate the world that we live in we
did reach out and we asked the
fellowship of friends to comment on
these allegations from former members as
well as their business interests and
they did not respond this was
enlightening I really think it was
because you can get something now in the
world so quickly it brings about a very
good question of do you ever really know
where something is coming from now baby
keep the glass I'm good I'm not gonna
finish the wine even though it's good
seems like he got drunk with power he
should've just drank it on wine on a
larger scale I guess the question is if
we take this as a very extreme example
but do we ever actually truly know
exactly where the goods we purchase come
from until then I will just press my own
juice I guess I'm definitely a anymore
this wine though and also I've been six
months sober and this is you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]